what is President some words are right
what was on the fact of Liberty what is
his method what would it be me first and
first i think i would say leave us alone
he would dismantle it and put up a
statue of himself all my relatives came
over as refugees and only a few hundred
on my calendar I'm carrying the sign are
you familiar with the poem is written on
the second oh yeah absolutely and I like
everyone else who's not a Native
American am a child grandchild of
immigrant my family all came through
Ellis Island so it has it particularly
very deep meaning to me my family every
American because everyone came here as a
mayor and everyone is saying twenty
percent of americans are immigrant and
on one of them what would you imagine
the words on the Statue of Liberty might
read if President Trump where's your
mind na Cola what a great question go
away you know come if you're rich white
people that would help us advance you
know economically not in any other sort
of way so the poem would be about him he
wouldn't say a poem because he's not
that intelligent it would just be a gold
statue with svorski crystals like to
hold of him ensure that this fantasy
you